of Ukraine Mr zielinski and his wife
Elena met the Polish president Andres
duder and the first lady of Poland let's
just drop in actually because they are
meeting right now
um the two leaders so let's just listen
into what they have to say
we need to stand a bit longer shoulder
to shoulder
that's why I want to thank
uh you for this reward
means a lot for those
who are carrying this Victory on their
shoulders
we have of all the ukrainians I thank
you for the warm words
that Mr Duda said
and and
from all those who are defending our
country and who are working on the
victory of Ukraine and thank you to
Poland and all the Europeans
thank you
sewing Embrace there between the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
and his polish counterpart Andres Duda
this is um zelinski's first official
visit to Poland since the beginning of
the war in Ukraine so let's bring in our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
who's in Warsaw for us today and Poland
has provided some key military as well
as personal support to Kiev haven't they
Siobhan so is this visit about zelinski
saying thank you
so officially this is a thank you visit
um it is the first official state visit
that president zielinski has made to
Poland and as you say Poland has been a
huge supporter of Ukraine since the war
broke out so we saw president zielinski
arriving here just over an hour ago he
was given a full
official welcome there was a band he
went and met the troops uh the first
ladies were there as well watching on
and now he seems to have gone inside to
have further talks with President Duda
and then also it seems being presented
with this medal now you heard there from
inside that meeting that he was taking
the opportunity there to say thank you
to Poland we know that Polish people are
exceptionally supportive of Ukraine at
least 80 percent of them in a recent
poll said that they wanted Ukraine to
continue getting support from both the
EU NATO and the Polish themselves until
the war was one so that just shows you
the high level of support and then also
in terms of Military Support we saw for
example Poland were very key in helping
to push and put pressure on the Germans
to ensure that the leopard 2 tanks were
released so that they could send them
they've sent some we also know of course
they've been discussing with them about
fighter jets and also sending migs so
things like that big levels of support
so what's happening today is this
meeting with the president and this
afternoon president zielinski will go on
and meet the Prime Minister and then
later this evening we're understanding
that he's going to meet people who have
moved here from Ukraine so refugees from
Ukraine around a million have been taken
in by Poland we saw of course they were
very welcoming opening their borders
after that Invasion happened last
February so he's going to be meeting
some of the people who have been
displaced here as well as meeting some
of the Polish people who have supported
them so on the headline this is a thank
you Mission but other important things
to discuss no doubt we'll probably hear
another call from president zielinski
asking for further weapons from both
Poland and partners but also there is a
trickier issue as well in terms of
Ukrainian grain which has been pushing
down the prices for Polish Farmers
that's causing a lot of anger for Polish
Farmers we've seen the agricultural
Minister here resign today over that
issue so that will be another thing
being discussed behind the scenes
okay Siobhan I know you'll keep a close
eye on President zielinski and his
movements during that visit but for the
moment